de toute façon l'être humain n'est pas
fait pour être carnivores saiss et c'est
important de le savoir
notre hattestad vrai beaucoup trop long
donc que la viande y séjourneraient très
trop longtemps il stagnerait trop
longtemps et nous n'avons pas la
dentition des carnivores
donc non le l'être humain est végétarien
cela vous étonne peut-être mais nous
commençons par manger les fruits en
début de repas parce que le fruit
contenant de l'eau ça nous permettra de
me voir moins pendant le repas et c'est
aussi pour faciliter la digestion
je crois que ce qui est important chez
les végétariens c'est que le palais
c'est vraiment apprécier la saveur de
chacun des légumes et je dois dire que
c'est très agréable et que cela nous
suffit
là par exemple je prépare une mayonnaise
sans eux à l'aide de purée d'amande et
d'huile d'olive à laquelle j'ajoute un
peu de citron elle me servir à
agrémenter mon riz complet pour le repas
de ce soir cela a commencé par donc
acheter un livre nourri ton corps
que j'ai remis gentiment à mon épouse
pour la lecture elle m'a raconté trois
pages elle m'a dit c'est formidable et
puis là dessus nous avons commencé
laborieusement
on a fait à manger au début c'était très
difficile n'avions plus l'habitude
mastiquer nos aliments alors il a fallu
mastiquer nous pouvions même pu parler à
table c'est en était pris par la
mastication
et puis gentiment mon épouse a commencé
à
faire de la bonne cuisine parce qu'au
début c'était vraiment pas très
appétissant
même non pas les enfants n'appréciez pas
oui il faut abandonner totalement les
anciennes recettes
et puis réétudier les choses d'une autre
façon alors au début on ne réussit pas
très bien c'est plein et on laisse même
des choses au sein des des plats mais
petit à petit ça s'arrange et maintenant
je pense que les enfants apprécient
et bien je suis donné pensionnaires
montini
et hier par exemple comme menu nous
avons eu en crudité des carottes râpées
un plat de viande et des légumes
petits pois et je n'ai pas mangé de
viande
parce que je sais que c'est c'est pas
bon j'ai pris que des légumes et des
crudités et j'ai mangé ma pomme j'étais
demi-pensionnaires l'année dernière et
puis au fur et à mesure que
je me suis
enfin mon corps je pensais s'est habitué
au végétalisme et alors j'ai eu des
ennuis de santé parce que je vais
continuer à manger
mal entre guillemets à l'école et alors
cette année je je suis externe je rentre
entre me dit quoi on pourrait croire en
effet que
cela revient plus cher mais quand vous
abandonnez la viande qui est très cher
le fromage et bien d'autres choses en
faisant mes comptes je me suis rendu
compte que
je re veut cela me revenaient même moins
cher au point de vue alimentaire et
qu'il y a autre chose encore à ajouter
c'est que nous n'avons pratiquement plus
je dois dire même plus du tout de
dépenses pour le nectar en étant moins
toxiques et on est moins moins agressif
on est on n'est pas malade on a le
cerveau déjà eu plus
plus plus plus dégagée plus lucide c'est
ainsi que les végétariens et végétaliens
sont plus tournés vers les tisanes vers
l'homéopathie vers l'acupuncture
c'est à dire toutes les méthodes qui
emploient des moyens naturels de
traitement nous sommes contre la paix
nous sommes appréciés les végétariens et
sont contre la vexation parce que y'a
quand même humidité l'immunité naturelle
qui jour le fait que notre ne compte de
notre corps est plus un donc nous sommes
immunisés et les vaccinations n'ont pas
lieu d'être je suis moi aussi contre les
vaccinations d'une manière générale
parce que les vaccinations introduisent
dans l'organisme des effets secondaires
que nous ignorons presque totalement
mais ceci ne veut pas dire que il faut
éliminer la nécessité d vaccination
dans tout l'est dans tous les cas contre
le tabac bien sûr contre l'alcool et
puis contre la violence en face et c'est
très vaste un esprit sain passe par un
corps sain
l'éliminent de sa vie courante les
excitants les tranquillisants les
calmants pour avoir recours plus à la
force morale force nerveuse
qui est en lui même je pense que le
végétarisme et plus particulièrement le
végétalien
conduit à reconnaître une puissance
supérieure à reconnaître qu'il y à un
mètre dans tout cela
le végétarisme et le végétalisme se
rapproche de la pureté originelle
nous avons appris remparts la lecture de
certains livres que la maladie était la
rançon du péché
et à ce titre ça nous a posé des
questions et on s'est demandé comment
comment es possible
qu'un malade
soit soit responsable de sa maladie ça
nous a même un peu révolté et une phrase
si vous voulez que j'ai découvert ya pas
très longtemps dans l'évangile où il est
dit le saigne le christ dit au
paralytique lève toi et marche et ne
pêche plus
je n'avais jamais compris cette
signification jusque là et depuis j'ai
fait un rapprochement entre
la nourriture et la conduite de notre
vie
[Musique]